okay then folks might as well get
started hello there my name is Matt
thank you for coming my name is Matt I
work for JetBrains I'm a developer
developer advocate and today we're gonna
talk about writing allocation free code
in c-sharp and we're gonna start really
with a little bit of advice very very
simple advice now it's something we
should feel like is beginning a bit
traditional with some of the talks I'm
gonna give here because it's a simple
one don't do it don't do it this is a
talk about micro optimizations and on
the whole you're not really going to
need to do this so generally speaking
you probably want to do this you've
probably ignore a lot of the things I'm
gonna say here but it's very very useful
to know because you're not going to need
to do this until you actually do need to
do this and then of course the only
reason you're gonna be doing that is by
measuring so please you know the things
I'm gonna point out today there's
they're interesting stuff it's useful to
know in and of itself but don't just
apply these things without measuring
first this is the big slide this is my
caveat my warning my disclaimer you've
all heard it so we'll move on right why
why are we talking about this and what
is what's so important about writing
allocation free code and I think one of
the problems really is that working with
c-sharp is very nice language to work
with the done at runtime is very nice
platform to work on we've got used to
having managed memory and we get used to
the runtime dealing with everything for
us we allocate stuff it cleans it all up
for us we don't need to think about it
we've got this ideas that manage memory
is cheap and that's not strictly true
allocation is cheap more or less you
know we run time gets a big block of
memory from the operating system and
within that then it manages the memory
for us and when we need to allocate
something it effectively just moves
things on at the end and gives us a
little block there so allocation is nice
and cheap but garbage collection is
expensive we've got this block of memory
we've want to sort of mark everything in
there which is no longer being used as
unused and to clean it up we have to
work all the way through all that and
then move it compact everything down and
clean things up so it's the garbage
collection thing which is expensive so
we're not really talking in this
particular instance about using too much
more
but it's about your memory throughput
are you memory throughput here it means
that your peak memory might actually be
quite low so you might not be sitting
there at 4 gigabytes of address space
full wondering where all my memory is
gone you might be sitting there
something you know nice and low and
reasonable but over a period of time
your memory traffic the amount of memory
you have allocated and have cleaned up
could be absolutely huge and this can
this this whole issue with throughput
can cause problems for you so the idea
is more allocations mean more garbage
collections more garbage collections
introduced in pauses into your code and
those pauses then disrupt throughput so
better throughput essentially gives you
a smoother experience with your
application there this doesn't
necessarily mean that things will be
faster they probably will be but it
might just be that things are smoother
rather than spectacularly faster but
better throughput really it's good for
areas where you'd need to do things with
a which require a bit of low latency so
servers if you want to try and get a
very good response time out of a web
server for example or a game if you're
writing a game you don't want things to
be stuttering you want your frame rate
to be good and quick and things sort of
thing with interactive user interfaces
as well just just you don't want to be
having you know typing away in your
editor and all the sudden the garbage
collection kicks in and you have to wait
a second or two before you can carry on
typing thank you and you know so it's
always good for a certain number of
things there but a lot of applications
fit into those kind of things so this
does work and while I'm saying is don't
do all these sort of micro optimizations
we can talk about this is still really
useful things to be thinking about as
you are writing your applications it's
also useful if you ever working in a
constrained environment such as mobile
devices consoles and so on where you
don't have as much memory as you would
do on a big desktop machine or on a
laptop so generally speaking using less
memory as a good thing so you want to
reduce your allocations anyway and if
you're on a less powerful device as well
your garbage collections might actually
be slower so again by reducing the
number of allocations you have you have
fewer garbage collections and things can
then
be a whole lot smoother and and quicker
and again talking about throughput mean
if we're talking constrained environment
if you're talking mobile devices mobile
gaming is a big huge business so for
example unity is a is a big deal on
mobile space there's they have a
statistic where the 50% of the
applications on mobile are written in
unity and of course unity is a dotnet
environment it's running on mono
but it's still c-sharp it's mono is the
garbage collection so the garbage
collector manage memory and so on so
these things are very important and
finally another reason to do this is is
really to know your platform so we work
at different layers of abstraction and
I'm a big believer in the idea that you
should know the layer below you're
working at so you can better understand
the code they are actually writing as
something interesting here as well is
that even if you don't use it you're
still going to be using it the things
I'm talking about today you're still
going to be using it because the
platform is using it so if the platform
is using it and you're getting a boost
of performance just from the platform
itself it's useful to know what's
happening and why it's happening and how
it's happening and I think it's useful
to point out that performance is a key
part of the design of the platform as
well so you can see this in things like
c-sharp recently had tuples added to it
and there's a perfectly good type there
they could have used that could view
system topple it's been there for years
it's been in the base class library but
they didn't they use system top valuable
and that's because system topple itself
is a class it's a reference type and
then you can allocate that and it'll sit
on your heap and did I'll get garbage
collecting and so on where it's value
types are implemented as struts and as
value types and that can then lead to
less allocations and be a whole lot more
useful there's a similar thing with IA
sync enumerator which is going to be
part of the weight for each feature in C
sharps 8 and what they're using there
that's going to be using tasks but what
attracting interviews there is value
tasks so again is something which
doesn't necessarily require an
allocation
and then of course we've got spam of T
which is a very new type which have been
introduced there and it's a really
interesting type for working with blocks
of memory and for subsets of blocks and
memories without allocations so
performance is really kind of being
thought about as they're designing and
building the platform all right so if
we're going to talk about allocation
free it's not just allocation free but
it's also about reducing your
allocations so if there's a bunch of
things you can do here without having to
work with some of the new things like
the span of tea and so on which you can
do to help reduce your allocations so
the simple one there object reuse if
you've got a list or an array which
you're going to be populating or
anything keep that around and pass it
back in again use it you know empty it
clear it and reuse it
same with objects you can do object
pooling and you can do all those kinds
of things string concatenation is an
obvious one which is going to allocate
stuff for you you can there's this types
which can help with that obviously
string builder is going to be a good one
for that parameters now params arguments
this is an interesting one because this
is something where by the compiler is
going to be creating allocations for you
which you might not be aware of so if
you've got a parameter applicator params
arguments based method like on the Left
they're passing in a array of strings
you want to be able to call it nice and
conveniently with a set of values that
are going on there what you actually end
up is the compiler allocating an array
for you and what's even more interesting
is when you have an empty method call it
still generates an array for you and it
generates an empty array and it'll
allocate that every time you call it so
you need to be aware of these kinds of
things when it's happening and even more
you have to be careful of people telling
you that because that's not strictly
true it depends on which framework and
which versions are compiled you're on
because the newer versions of a
framework new versions of the compiler
will actually use the arrayed are empty
type sorry method and that will then use
a static instance which is shared across
different
generic instances instantiations of the
types there
so what we get in a modern compiler and
a modern version of the framework is a
is no allocations going on there so you
kind of need to measure this you need to
know what's actually going on there you
can't just trust that somebody's telling
you the truth and not trying to stitch
you up onstage okay another one which is
useful as well is is boxing this one's a
good one to understand this is about the
sort of reference types and value types
again and this is about passing a value
type to a method which expects a
reference type this doesn't happen this
doesn't work terribly well and you have
to do sort of convert your value type
into a reference type and that allocates
a new object on the heap which contains
a copy of the object
right hang on a minute let's do a bit of
back to basics here reference types and
very sighs everyone know everyone's
heard about reference and value types
excellent very good so the differences
are really fairly sort of substantial I
mean the first one is an easy one you've
got reference types defined by the
keyword class and value types with the
struct keyword and one of the big
difference is is how they are allocated
and dealing with memory a reference type
is allocated on the heap so you got a
big area of memory to be used purely for
allocating objects like this and then
you got value types Ritter allocated on
the stack you can also embed a value
type inside a reference type which is
fun and so that means you've got an
actual copy of that data inside your
reference object so if you have a person
object for example when it contains an
int containing their age or their date
of birth or whatever then that is
actually copied directly into the person
object key difference is also how they
are being used so a variable for a
reference type is a reference to the
thing on the heap so if you've got a
variable it's pointing it's saying it's
over there that's where the thing is on
the heap whereas a variable for a value
type is the value itself so this
variable here now it's just an integer
it's 42 is that it's the number it's the
value and that then affects how things
are passed around into methods so if
you've got a variable which is
referencing it's over here
when you're calling a method all you do
is you pass that reference to the method
and now this method says oh it's this
thing over here it's pointing at the
same thing it's using the same thing it
knows how to do it it's a reference it
says it's over here however with a value
type you pass a copy of it around you
pass around by value and so that means
if you have the value 42 then this other
method here gets a value of 40 - but
it's a copy of the value it's not the
same value itself so with integers it
doesn't necessarily matter you're not
going to change it but with some other
value types so for example a
two-dimensional point of X&Y you might
want to change one of the values the X
or the Y value but because you've got
two different copies here it's not going
to affect the original one and this is
something which is a very important very
useful to know and to know what the
difference is and it this doesn't just
affect passing things in two methods
either this also affects assignment so
if you make an assignment of a reference
type so you know person p1 equals p2
then that's just copying the reference
is still pointing at the same item
whereas if you have two two-dimensional
points point one and point two if you
assign that that's a copy and so again
you're not going to be able to change
the original version by changing the
copy does that kind of make sense so far
excellent because I've also been talking
about the heap versus the stack and it's
not necessarily very clear what that's
all about as well and so high-level view
really is a heap is is general-purpose
memory you can just think of it of as
some where you can put your objects and
they they just live and the big
difference really here is that this can
last for the applicate that the lifetime
of the application so you allocate
something it lives in the heap and as
long as something's using it it can stay
around for the lifetime of the
application where it's the stack is a
block of memory which is just for
storing local data that is required by
methods and each method when it's called
it pushes some space onto the stack and
it can then have all of its local
variables inside that that space there
and when it does that method finishes
we'll pop the stack it'll clear that
stack it'll drop it back down to where
it was before and that space which was
being used for local variables is is
gone so those local variables are gone
and this means that snack allocation is
for the lifetime of a method so we've
got heap which is lifetime of
potentially the application or as long
as you need it whereas the stack is only
just for method lifetime when we create
value types they're created on the stack
and because value types are the actual
whole data that whole data lives
directly on the stack so if we want to
put a two-dimensional point on the stack
it just lives there straight on the
stack there's nothing going off to to
the heap or anywhere else this means
then that allocation is cheap because
it's just on the stack it's right there
so we've already got that with the heap
that's fine but cleanup is cheap as well
because we're just getting rid of the
getting rid of the stack but you are
limited because your lifetime of that
object is limited
it's also worth pointing out the stack a
lock keyword as well this allows you to
create blocks of memory on the stack as
well so if you wanted to normally create
an array that would go in the heap but
with the stack Harlock you can actually
create it on the stack and have a block
of data there which you can then clear
up and meet as the eggs in so let's just
check so just to kind of recap them back
on some of the boxing stuff if you pass
a value type to a method which expects a
reference type it's not going to work
because you've got this you got these
two sort of incompatible types going on
here so what you have to do is you have
to convert your value type into a
reference type and you do that by
creating a box effectively the runtime
does this for you it creates something
in the object type because a value type
can live directly inside the data for a
reference type it just gets copied
straight over there and so now the
object sorry the method which expected
an object so for example
console.writeline here that's expecting
a string value or an object which you
can call to string on i'm passing an
integer int to that an integer is trying
to be convert into an object it can't do
it it has to get boxed has to be put
into something that can be used and
could be passed around
the original value is now in a box it
can't be changed because it's a copy if
you change it it doesn't affect the
original value okay so let's have
another couple of things then which
might be causing allocations which might
not be aware of closures closures we've
got a something like here we've got a
lambda going on with a message there
we're using the name value which is
being passed in as a parameter to the
message there when you write a lambda
like this which is using variables
inside it as the compiler will rewrite
that into a class it'll pull that class
out and pull those variables out those
variables become fields on the class and
it will allocate that class for you to
capture that information so there's an
allocation going on there you can see it
here as we being told the the name
parameter is being captured as part of
this closure
this affects everywhere we're using
closures and one of the places that we
use closures a lot is in link where
we're using our select our where clauses
our first or default and so on and that
can then have an effect on us so if we
doing a lot of chained calls for links
we're actually gonna be allocated making
quite a few of these allocations and
even further then link itself the way
it's implemented a lot of the time it
will allocate an object which will be
the enumerator itself so you'll have an
object which is the numerator which will
then keep a capture of this closure
class and you've got more allocations
going on so one of the nice things you
can do though is here and for example in
the boxing example there we can use some
various plugins to show us these kind of
things so one of the one of the guys on
the resharper team wrote a plugin a
while ago called the heap allocation
viewer and this is really useful because
it'll highlight where there are these
kind of hidden allocations going on
these allocations which are not explicit
they're not there because you give
called new but they're being done behind
the scenes for you and these can then
sort of inform you then when you've got
allocations going on you've got a sort
of similar sort of thing with iterators
as well if you're using yield would
yield return that gets rewritten into a
state machine there's an object which
gets created and allocated for you and
also async/await you see it's even more
sort of complicated there your codes
rewritten to a state machine again but
you also get that state machine
allocated plus also a task method
builder and all the sort of accompanying
infrastructure around that that gets
allocated and when you are creating a
task to return whether it's a task or a
task of T that's going to get allocated
as well and so this can be expensive for
some of the common use cases so if
you've just got a simple synchronous
return I'm calling an async method but
it's already got the value I'm having to
allocate an object just to return you an
object that I've already got so that can
be an expensive thing going on there
also tasks of T for example has a lot of
or a lot it has support for for read
reuse I can call I can get my value out
of my tasks again and again and again it
kind of caches things for us and some of
that infrastructure then has a cost and
so one of the things that has happened
in recent releases is this value task
type and there's a nice link here which
explains a whole lot about it it's a
value type which kind of is a very
lightweight version of tasks and task of
T and it's only really useful in certain
scenarios but it's in the most common
sort of scenarios there so it's useful
this link here I've got a slide at the
end with some links there so if you want
to grab that later that's no problem
but it's a really good article about how
and when you should use value tasks
right let's have a look at something a
little more fun and interesting
reference semantics with value types
which is a big mouthful for a whole lot
of nice little features which have been
added in recent versions of c-sharp
seven so c-sharp seven has had point
releases and and seven point two added a
bunch of things which really gives us
some nice stuff here couple of things
were in c-sharp 7.0 but most of this
came in 7.2 we've got a few things we've
got ref locals and ref returns ref
read-only read-only structs ref struts
and in parameters so that sounds great
doesn't it but you know
what am I talking about what does this
all actually sort of mean and it's the
idea that allocating a reference type
allocating and freeing and having
managed memory here has a cost you know
so with the garbage collection and so on
but passing it around is cheap it's nice
and cheap to pass a reference to another
object and it's all pointing at the same
object and you can use it and you can
modify it and it gets used whereas on
the other hand allocating a value type
is cheap it's cheaper to allocate and
free a value type but passing it around
has a cost if you're paying for the the
copy although that's not necessarily
terribly expensive but your password you
will also have the downside of not being
able to modify that so why can't we have
the best of both worlds and that's what
reference semantics with value types
allows us to do so put simply it allows
value types to be used just like a
reference type we can pass it in and we
can pass it by reference everywhere and
we can modify it and that'll
modification will affect the original
version as well so this allows us to
reduce allocations it reduces the copies
that we're making as the value types go
around and overall then it just reduces
our memory traffic and this is a good
thing so again very low-level micro
optimizations you probably won't want to
do this but in the times that you do
want to do this this will be really cool
and it's always gonna be used in the
platform which is also very useful it'll
be used in the platform to be used in
games it'll be used in parsing in
serialization and so on so this will
probably mostly affect you by using
libraries where other people have done
this but when you have a very critical
Hopf pass in your code this might
actually help you okay but what does
pass by reference and pass by value sort
of mean and again it's the idea that a
variable for a reference type is a
reference to this object living on the
heap whereas the variable for the value
type itself is the value so a variable
of an integer is the number 42 is this
the value passing a reference type to a
method is just passing the reference so
the message sees the same object it's
that object over there if I modify that
object over there
both the caller and the called object
see the changes
passing the value type to a method
copies the value and if you assign it to
another value as well then you also copy
the value the original value is
unmodified and it's also important to
point out the copies aren't actually
that expensive but if you're talking
about micro optimizations if you're
talking about these kinds of change low
level optimizations then they do start
to add up ok so the first feature will
that kind of works with this there's all
built on top of each other and they sort
of build up then to give you the full
feature set is the idea of ref return
this allows you to return a reference to
a value type rather a copy of it
normally if you return back an integer
or at a two-dimensional point you'll get
a copy of that value but he can return
now a reference to the value so the
return type of the method becomes a
reference so it's not just return value
of int or a point to D it's a reference
to an int or a reference to a point to D
that introduces a constraint the
lifetime of that object the returned
value it must exceed the lifetime of the
called method so I can't return a
variable in the called method because a
variable in the called method lives in
that stack but the message has just
cleaned up the stack and so it's gone
and so I can't have a reference to
something that's just gone so it's got
to be something which lasts for longer
so this would be a field or a method
argument because you got passed in if it
got passed in it must exist outside the
lifetime without method and so we have
to use that modifying the reference is
the same as modifying the original value
because it's a reference it's the actual
thing itself and you can do some real
interesting things with that there you
can have a return reference to an array
cell so to learn item with an array and
update that and so you're actually
updating the value in the array itself
without touching the array which is a
bit weird but cool the way use it is
nice and easy you just add the ref
modifier to the declaration to the
method declarations return type and to
the return statement itself and one
thing that's important to point out is
you can't use it
a sync message because they get
rewritten into a class and it gets
pulled out and there you can't sort of
justify the lifetime anymore but now
that we're returning a reference how do
we use it because if I try and put a
reference into a variable of an integer
that's an integer so I can put a
reference into an integer on e to put an
integer into an integer so how do we use
it and that's what the ref local feature
is all about if I'm returning a
reference back I need to have a
reference to put it into so if I try to
assign it to a do it to a non reference
type it will create a copy of it and
that's not what we want we want to use
the whole reference so ref local it's a
variable that is a reference to a value
type and accessing that will use the
original value and the key thing here as
well is that if you're using var don't
get caught out by thinking that the type
inferencing will work for you here
because the var will tell you what the
value type is but you still need the ref
modifier so we'd use 'href VAR to be
able to use type inferencing all right
so let's have a quick look at some some
code so I have a point class here which
has got an x and y values there I'm
creating it with a constructor and I
have an enemy class as well
which takes in a point as a constructor
value and I can get it
I can get the location which will just
return it return it back or I can use
this get location by ref that's got the
ref keyword as part of the Declaration
and as part of the return statement as
well and we have some tests now which
will sort of then verify behavior so if
I create a new value here which is going
to be an enemy at point 10 10 I can get
the location I can set it to be 12 and I
can confirm that it has actually worked
on that location but if I get it back
now we can actually see that my expected
value is 10 because it hasn't changed
anything because it's a copy
so if
we just quickly run that one tell you
what let's clear all those because I
can't see which one was which one just
ran if I could press the right keyboard
shortcut
cuz I'm tight okay let's try that again
run that one we see the one test that
we've got and it's green so it worked
with a copy because I was pulling back I
wasn't doing it by reference so in the
next test then I'm doing get location by
ref this is going to return me back my
value using return ref here but I'm
going to put it into another point which
is a value type and so it's actually
going to be a copy and I can confirm
that again if I change it and then get
the value back again it's still ten if I
use ref are here I can change the value
then and my expected value tells me it
should be twelve it should be changed
and if we run that one we've got green
and everything's good so we're working
we know when we're working with copies
and when we're working with actual
reference but you can do something weird
as well which is fun so you can have a
method as the left hand side of a call
there so we can have enemy dark get
location by ref as a method as the left
hand side of a thing and assign a new
point to it which is bonkers because
it's returning back a reference to the
field what we're doing is we're
assigning a new value directly to that
field and so that one's changed there
and so where it really was 10 10 is now
42 42 because we've just overwritten
that field because it was a reference
don't make sense
good that one hurts my head that wanders
flaky method on the left-hand side it's
just strange okay next one then is in
parameters this is an argument to method
parameters
no sorry a modifier to method arguments
it was written right there and this kind
of complements the out and ref keywords
as well so you've got an in keyword this
allows you to pass things in by
reference but the method is not allowed
to modify
original value so whereas a ref passes
something in and get it out out just
gets a value out in just gets a value in
by reference but there's a problem the
idea isn't the method can't modify the
original value but there's no way for
the compiler to enforce that because the
compiler or others there's no way for
the compiler to know that because any
property or method on a struct can
change its own state and if it changed
its own state it would come back and it
would have changed and that's not good
because the whole point was is an imp
aramet err and you shouldn't be able to
change it so the compiler enforces
safety it makes a defensive copy when
you're calling a member we can have a
look at that as well so if we have some
in parameters here I've got a mutable
point so I've got x and y values here
and yes the public fields so anybody
could change them anyway but we'll
ignore that we've got a constructor
which is hanging things up and I've got
a translate in place which is just doing
a simple translate with my x and
y-coordinates that are going on there
and I can run this calling methods here
and we can see that this works where are
we let's show in parameters there so
everything works ok I can pass in 10 and
I can translate it in place and it's all
works and it's all good now if I
uncomment this now this should be this
should be fine that's a neuron as well
we've got a test here where I'm trying
to modify the in parameter so I create a
new point at 10 10 I pass it into a
message where it's got an in parameter
marked on there and they are trying
assert that it's it's not being changed
and in here I try and change it but the
compiler says you can't change this you
can't access these value here I can't
modify a struct member on my public
field because it's not classes as a
variable because it's an Imperator
you're not allowed to change it but I
can still call translate in place and
when I do that I will get a copy of it
and it won't change I'll get my
defensive copy
so let me just undo my code which
doesn't compile and then we have another
test here then which will which will do
that then it will call translate in
place on an in parameter there and it
will wake up in a sec it will die on me
[Music]
right we close and reopen the solution
so yes so this one will create a new
instance it will call the do translate
on with a variable no with an argument
which is got the in modifier and we will
then see that it's called on a defensive
copy and we'll see that translate didn't
work am I actually gonna have to kill
everything yeah let's kill that right
we'll just pretend that test worked and
we'll move on to the next slide okay so
it sings things a good day we've got
some immutability going on but we still
got copies and things happening and so
you know we can pass things around by
reference but we've still got copies and
we want to reduce that that's the whole
point that we don't want these so we've
got another feature name which is the
ref read-only return this extends ref
returns and ref locals by telling the
tenants that we can't modify it so this
is an interesting one here because we're
returning a value by reference but the
caller is not allowed to modify it so we
can assign to a referee ball here and
the compiler enforces read-only again
with more errors and we're we're there
is this time and also defensive copies
so for example here we've got a point
which we've defined as a static static
field they're a point of origin of zero
zero zero and I'm returning that as a
reference if I was returning it as a
reference somebody could change my
origin and that would be really bad for
any kind of game I was trying to write
and so what we can do is say that and
say it's a ref read-only now if I try
and assign that to a variable to avow
then I would get a copy of it and it
would work like that if I try to assign
it to a to a read-only var then I will
get a reference to it but when I'm
making invocations there we will get
copies being made no just keeping an eye
on time I'm going to move on without
demos on this one we will quickly look
at read-only struct this isn't like the
next level on again so it's an in
parameters and refereed only can still
create defensive copies because the
compiler doesn't know that the structs
methods will modify States
so then c-sharp 7.2 introduced a
read-only struct instead so you mark a
struct as read-only you then have to
mark all of your fields in there as
being read-only as well and so you get
an immutable struct and then the
compiler knows that it can't change
anything or so that your methods can't
change anything because all of your
fields are read-only and so you know
it's a mutable in its state it's there
and again no copies get made so again
micro optimization but we're missing out
on copies key thing with all of this is
there's no changes to the CLR so that's
a good thing
it's just all in the code normally in
the compiler and in c-sharp
seven-point-two added an extra thing
which is a ref struct and to be
perfectly don't know why it's called a
ref struct but this is a type which can
only be allocated on the stack so this
is a struct which can only live on the
stack so it can never be part of a
referent of a reference type so I
couldn't have a person with a containing
a ref struct because my person sorry I
could never have a person class
containing a ref struct because that
would not live on the stack so this
constrains the lifetime to the calling
method it also means that it can't be
boxed it can't be used inside a non ref
struct can't be used with async methods
or instances and it calm
because they get rewritten into classes
I can't use a generic parameter either
this then has very limited use cases but
they're very cool so the first one is
working with stack alec memory and the
second n is span of T which is a really
cool type which is all about working
unifying the way we work with a big
block of memory so you can work with
things like arrays or array segments
strings and substrings native memory
stack allocated memory all in the same
sort of manner basically you get a lot
of it looks like an array but for lots
of different types of backing memory so
you have an array like API you have an
indexer and so you can do your item
there square brackets 12 and get of the
value that's in there or set the value
that's there there's also a ret a
read-only span which provides just a
getter so you can't modify the values
that are underneath it but it's there
it's also typesafe each element is a
type t you can get ahold of it you just
work with it just as normal so it is
very much like an array and it has array
like performance so it's not quite as
performance new runtimes have special
support for it which make it basically
the same as arrays but that's it and
they're they're good and the key thing
the really useful thing with it is is
slicing you can create a new span which
is based on a subsection of an existing
span so you can then say that my span is
this block of memory here and you can
create a new span which is based on that
block of memory there and you don't have
to make a copy of it so it's using the
same memory the way it's implemented is
that it's a value type so again no
copies going around anywhere you need to
bring in the system memory NuGet package
it's built into dotnet core 2.1 but the
package will then give you some
reference types for different frameworks
that are there it supports the darknet
standard 1.1 and above so it wrote works
on dotnet framework 4.5 and above but
the new versions of the of dotnet core
have it have support directly in the
runtime for it there's also new API is
an overlay loads in the base class
library some of these would be part of
the next version of the dotnet standard
so things like read async tripe ours
will be able to return you back as spam
this is really good if you're writing a
parser because then you can have read a
line of text and then split it up into
little little strings without having to
allocate new strings there are two
different versions so if we're talking
about this we're talking about
performance there's two different
versions there's a portable version and
a fast version the fast version requires
runtime support and this is in dotnet
core 2.1 and above
I think it's 2.1 maybe 2.0 I've
certainly confused myself I think it's
2.1 the portable version works on a
standard 1.1 and above which is dartnet
frame at 4.5 it's important to say the
portable version is not slow it's not as
fast as the fast version but it's not
slow it's also not as fast as a race the
way it works is by holding the object
that you're working with and offset into
that object and in the length so you can
get that item there whereas the fast
version requires runtime support the way
it works is it holds an internal pointer
so if you've got the object here it
holds an internal pointer and the length
and so it's slightly smaller and
accessing a particular element is
slightly simpler but more importantly
the runtime has specific JIT op
optimizations here so it can ignore the
the bounce check in a loop just like it
does with arrays so you get very very
close to array like performances so what
does this have to do with ref struct and
the big thing is it is a ref struct that
the problem is for thread safe do you
need to update all of these fields
inside a span of T atomically you can't
do it sort of you know you can't have
one part of the pointer difference in
these then change the length at a
different time you've got to have it
done at the same time and you know
because the whole point of this is
performance you can't do that with
standard locking synchronization it's
also the case that the internal pointers
that the fast version use are quite
expensive so you don't to have too many
of those happening at any one time we
want to deal with lots of blocks of
memory lots of different types of many
such as stack a lock but if it's
stack allocated thing how do you deal
with that if your span is living on the
heap the stack can disappear at any time
and all of a sudden this span is somehow
invalid but you can't track that and
stuff so you make span of T a ref struct
can only be created on the stack he's
got constrained lifetime and
single-threaded access because the stack
only belongs to one thread okay I think
I've run out of time for my demo
certainly I can do a quick quick demo
right I'm gonna do this very quickly in
the minutes - so we've got a test here
span does not allocate I'm using dot
memory unit here which is a unit testing
framework for tracking memory usage you
create a check point here and we'll use
that later we create a string we convert
it into a span and we say we get we can
get a sub span of that which is going to
be between index is 0 and 5 and we can
even slice that span as well to get it
between 0 and 5 and then we can do a
bunch of asserts we can assert that it
starts with a particular string that
it's of a length of a particular length
and we can do a whole bunch of asserts
there and of at the very end we can
assert that there are zero objects
allocated that uses the dot memory unit
API to check to see whether any items
are allocated and very simply we can run
that oops and run it incorrectly so if I
just run my tests under dot memory unit
the profiler has to be running to run
these tests and so this the chicken and
egg scenario there you can't start the
profiler after you've started running
their tests so you have to run the tests
first
and we've got a first test there which
is actually showing that we've got an
object allocation with a string but then
we've got a second one there showing we
can do all that stuff with spans we can
create sub spans we can say we compare
different strings and string lengths
there without allocating anything
so apologies for the rush demo there and
so that brings me to the end and here's
some very useful links then on some of
these kinds of things the documentation
for reference semantics with value types
is very useful explains a whole lot of
this kind of stuff the good channel 9
video jared parsons where he's
explaining what span of tea does out of
sit Nick also has a very good blog post
again sort of covering all this
information there there's details of
some of the optimizations in the JIT
which are based on how spam works and
then the last one there is the link from
earlier on which is Steven Tao
explaining the all about value task and
how and when you should be using it so
that brings me to the end two minutes
over apologies thank you very much
[Applause]